DENIED U.N. DIRECTOR HAS ACCESS
TO THE VESSEL BUT THAT COULD
SOON CHANGE.
>> I THINK THE WORLD WILL
ABSOLUTELY MAKE THEM PAY A
PRICE.
EVERY FOREIGN MINISTER THAT I
TALK TO, THEY RECOGNIZED WHAT
CHINA HAS DONE TO THE WORLD.
>> John: SECRETARY OF STATE
MIKE POMPEO SAYS HE BELIEVES THE
WORLD WILL HOLD THEM
ACCOUNTABLE.
GENERAL JACK KEANE IS A RETIRED
FOUR-STAR GENERAL, AND FOX NEWS
SENIOR STRATEGIC ANALYST.
WHAT PRICE MIGHT CHINA PAY?
THERE IS TALK THAT THE
WHITE HOUSE MAY IMPLEMENT TRAVEL
RESTRICTIONS FOR MEMBERS OF THE
CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY BUT THAT
ALSO SEEMS TO BE TIED TO CHINA’S
TREATMENT OF THE UIGHURS ON
WHAT’S GOING ON IN HONG KONG AND
NOT JUST CORONAVIRUS.
WHAT MIGHT BE FROM CHINA OVER
THIS WHOLE THING?
>> THERE WILL BE SOME
RETRIBUTION FOR THE PANDEMIC AND
THE FACT THAT THE OUTCRY AROUND
THE WORLD CERTAINLY IS WHAT WE
HAVE ALL SEEN THE COME OF THE
DECEPTION ABOUT THE ORIGINS OF
THE PANDEMIC.
AND, AND SIGNIFICANTLY THE
UNITED STATES.
SO RETRIBUTION IS THERE,
SANCTIONS ARE THERE AND WHAT IS
CHANGING HERE IS THE BROAD
COALITION DEVELOPING THE WORLD,
THAT IS BECOMING ANTI-CHINA.
IT GIVES THE UNITED STATES A
HUGE STRATEGIC OPPORTUNITY WITH
OUR PARTNERS AND ALLIES TO
DEVELOP A GRAND STRATEGY TO
CONFRONT CHINA AND CONTAIN THEIR
MALIGN AND AGGRESSIVE BEHAVIOR.
IT’S NOT JUST ABOUT THE PANDEMIC
BUT IT CERTAINLY IS THE CATALYST
FOR BRINGING THE COALITION
TOGETHER THAT SECRETARY
SECRETARY POMPEO IS BRINGING
TOGETHER.
>> SO HOW CHINA IS VIEWED AROUND
THE WORLD, AND THAT’S WHAT WE
ARE KIND OF DOING ANY KIND OF
BUSINESS WITH.
WE JUST SAID THAT’S NOT GOING TO
USE ANY WATERWAY PRODUCTS IN THE
CORE OF ITS 5G SYSTEM SO THAT IS
REALLY SHUTTING OUT CHINA.
AT LEAST IN THE U.K.
THEY WANTED TO RUN THE WORLD
TABLE IN TERMS OF OWNING 5G AND
WHICH MEANS OWNING MOST OF THE
TELECOM SYSTEMS IN THE WORLD IT
WOULD BE ABSOLUTELY DESTRUCTIVE
TO US.
IN TERMS OF INTELLECTUAL
PROPERTY AND ALSO OUR ALLIES.
THESE COUNTRIES ARE NOT PULLING
AWAY FROM WATERWAY RUNNING 5G
FOR THEM IF IT WAS NOT FROM THIS
MALIGN AND AGGRESSIVE
BEHAVIOR WITH PRESIDENT XI
DEALING WITH THE PANDEMIC.
I BELIEVE HISTORY WILL SHOW US
THAT PRESIDENT XI HAS BEEN THE
MOST AGGRESSIVE AND THE MOST
AMBITIOUS AND THE MOST MALIGN
LEADERS AND I THINK WE ARE GOING
TO SEE THAT HE OVERREACHED.
HE PUT THE CCP ON A FAST TRACK
TO ACHIEVE CHINA’S STREAM WHICH
IS DOMINATION CONTROL OF THE
ASIA PACIFIC AND PLACING THE
UNITED STATES IS THE WORLD’S A
GLOBAL LEADER.
HE THOUGHT THAT HE COULD ACHIEVE
THAT WITHIN THE NEXT FIVE OR SIX
YEARS AND THIS IS BLOWING UP IN
HIS FACE AS A RESULT OF HIS
AGGRESSIVE BEHAVIOR.
>> John: AND NOW THE
UNITED STATES IS SAYING THAT IT
THEY WILL STAND WITH THE
SOVEREIGNTY WHICH HAS BEEN
AFFRONTED BY CHINA’S NATIONS